conversation avec pendant 45 minutes
vous pouvez poser toutes vos questions
rien résolu et j'aurai le plaisir de les
relayer en soit en compagnie de sarah el
hariri qui est secrétaire d'état chargée
de la jeunesse et de l'engagement
bonjour sahara bonsoir bonsoir jean noël
évidemment dans le délai et dans aucune
de cet échange nous avons la chance de
pouvoir partager avec leurs toits ou je
n'ai pas besoin de le présenter c'est
évidemment notre président c'est le
maire de pons et en plus aujourd'hui le
haut commissaire au plan qui projettera
l'avenir et qui portera au coeur de
notre débat politique
les grandes transitions et le grand âge
et d'autres notre temps je vois que les
questions commencent et évidemment jean
noël prend d'abord monsieur président
françois à toi à toi l'honneur et puis
jean noël à toi l'honneur de poser aussi
les premières questions
je suis très content qu'on puisse
partager ce moment je remercie jean noël
et sarah deux d'être les relais des
questions que vous posez vous est ce que
je me trompe
la cabine technique et gina tiens c'est
un peu flou de l'image sur l'écran
c'est normal ça fait partie du média met
donc comme j'ai pas de réponse je vais
considérer que c'est lui et que vous
voyez à l'essentiel dès que vous vous
entendiez aussi donc si je comprends
bien jean domaine et sarah c'est vous
qui réveillé les questions avec d'abord
une première question d'olivier qui nous
demande
qui te demandes si dans les perspectives
qui vous ont été confiées
est il concevable d'imaginer une
démocratie athénienne la population vos
clés loi préparé par une combinaison
exécutif législatif annuellement
houle c'est une formulation un peu
hardie parce que démocratie athénienne
je sais bien que l'expression qu'on
emploie souvent mais c'est le contraire
de la vérité de la réalité à athènes
de même participé à six mille que les
citoyens de plein exercice était mieux
du temps les autres à peu près j'ai pas
95 cent de la population peut être été
des esclaves et les esclaves étaient
considérés comme des machines
ils avaient un cours comme les machines
agricoles et donc serait absolument
stupéfait un athénien du vème siècle on
puisse prétendre que les hommes et égaux
en droits alors après je pense qu'il
peut y avoir des expériences de
participation même de consultation sur
des sujets mais sur des sujets qui sont
des sujets accessible par l'opinion la
plupart des sujets que l'on doit traiter
lorsqu'on est à la tête du tas sont des
sujets qui demande un engagement si
profond syli si grave de la part des
dirigeants que je ne crois pas que cela
soit accessible
à une démarche référendaire passionnel
je vais prendre un exemple même ça nous
avons eu un référendum en 2005 sur
maastricht ce référendum s'est joué à un
cheveu
il se trouve que on a gagné
nous avons gagné nous et le ps puisque
c'étaient les deux forces qui étaient
favorables à maastricht on a gagné
qu'est ce que serait aujourd'hui la
situation du pays si la banque centrale
européenne n'existe pas ce que quelqu'un
peut réfléchir à ce que ça serait en
réalité si la banque centrale ne
rompaient n'existait pas on se
trouverait dans une situation où la
spéculation se déchaînerait contre
l'abonné française parce que nous
n'avions pas l'assise suffisante pour
pour soutenir la création d'une monnaie
respecté dans le monde entier une
immense avantage de l'avantageux vital
dans les moments que nous traversons
mais il aurait très bien pu se faire à
quelques centaines de milliers de voix
aux dizaines de milliers de voir que la
passion l'emportent sur la raison
il ya des moments j'en connais un autre
très bien lorsque dans l'avant guerre de
40 grande bretagne les débats publics
sont entièrement dominée par le
sentiment pacifiste de lobby et lorsque
la guerre arrive tu cherchais
va devant le parlement britannique et il
interroge son prédécesseur ministre
britannique pour savoir pourquoi j'ai
raconté ça dans un mini livre pourquoi
ils ont fait ce choix de désarmer la
grande et ce prédécesseur lui répond en
disant sans ces mots exacts je vais vous
répondre avec une effrayante sincérité
il dit l'opinion britannique était tout
entière pacifiste il se trouve que
j'étais à la tête d'un grand parti
un grand parti a le devoir de gagner les
élections
j'ai donc suivi les électeurs au lieu de
les conduire et vous voyez que le l'idée
que nous nous faisons de la
responsabilité d'un dirigeant d'homme
d'état d'un citoyen c'est pouvoir d'état
et citoyens ça devrait être la même
chose
un homme d'état et un citoyen ils ont un
devoir qui est de voir plus clair que
les autres et donc je ne crois pas que
la décision sur des sujets stratégiques
gravissime puissent être remises
complètement aurait fait la fête
4 cette projection cette capacité à voir
ce qui ce que beaucoup n'arrivais même
pas à définir et à projeter en fait le
pays dans les décennies qui arrive tu
imagines bien que les questions qui
arrivent sont très nombreuses et se
demande et te demande principalement ça
va être quoi ta savait trop à des sujets
prioritaires
en tant que haut commissaire ils vont
jusqu'à est ce assez maligne à jean
william gence la question de kamini ou
encore de françois comment quelles sont
les grandes priorités
comment sortir de la crise qui efface
sassano ou devant nous et surtout
une crainte qui est grandissante et
cette montée du populisme à
l'international à quel point ça peut
percuter notre vie politique
à quel point ça peut percuter les
transitions que nous sommes en train de
vivre qu'elle soit environnementale
sociale profondément mais également
industriel
les questions s'enchaînent donc on va
les prendre étape par étape mais je voit
se dessiner ce point commun qu'ils te
demandent pour toi quels sont les
éléments forts je sais que tu vas tu tu
auras l'occasion d'en de le présenter
dans le détail dans les jours qui
arrivent
mais si tu pouvais partager avec avec
avec nous mais quelques priorités qui te
paraissent saillantes quelle serait-elle
alors j'ai naturellement vous parlé avec
le président de la république de la
lettre de mission que qui est étriqué
qui va être rendu public dans les heures
qui viennent mais j'ai déjà je me suis
déjà exprimé sur au moins trois grandes
priorités
la première de ses priorités
c'est l'indépendance du pays
j'ai été extraordinairement frappé et
vous aussi sans doute dans la crise de
l'épidémie de police de la situation
dans laquelle nous nous sommes trouvés
nous et les autres pays européens nous
un grand pays médical nous un grand
prime de pharmacie et peut-être de
mettre les tic à la pharmacie avons nous
pensé pendant longtemps que nous étions
au tout premier rang des bourdes et puis
nous nous sommes trouvés dans une
situation de pénurie des médicaments
essentiels la la route de
l'approvisionnement de ces faits
cette route là avait quitté et puis je
ne parle pas seulement des masses ne
parle pas de moi même pas seulement dans
cette incroyable des produits anesthésie
du curare d'apartés mais les corticoïdes
les antibiotiques et les molécules pour
traiter le cancer savait que pour nous
tous ces jours ci c'est chimiothérapie
s'éteint c'est un souci damman très
importants et des raisons affectives et
que vous savez de la santé de marie-anne
est donc cette ce médicament là et même
le paracétamol doliprane
ces médicaments étaient en rupture sont
encore aujourd'hui fragilité en france
alors qu'est ce que c'est un pays qui se
fixe à l'avenir et qui est incapable
d'avoir l'approvisionnement élémentaire
dans bay dans des médicaments de cet
ordre pour moi c'est ni plus ni moins
l'acceptation d'une dépendance alors je
dois très bien pourquoi cette dépendance
s'est établie et ça nous ramène à la
question du plan on a vécu tous les pays
occidentaux depuis depuis madame
thatcher et monsieur régale tous les
pays occidentaux est vécue ont vécu avec
lui et que le plus efficace
c'était de laisser faire les décisions
économiques par les acteurs et coda
je comprends ce raisonnement je suis pas
en train de me de le détruire
je pense que pour ce qui est les
scissions économique le comment
dirais-je landa alors en effet cette
réalité est vrai mais lorsqu'il s'agit
des deux mêmes dont des morts la survie
et la suite ville de l'union européenne
parce que pour moi c'est ça ne se
distingue pas on a aussi avec des
médicaments en allemagne on déplore
profiter en france difficultés de nord
est donc cette préoccupation-là de voir
soumis à des décisions qui lui sont
totalement étrangères elle ne se
manifeste elle ne se manifeste pas
seulement dans la pollution des
médicaments qui se manifeste dans
beaucoup de ton production et dans
beaucoup d'autres décisions et le but ou
prenez plus que je considère comme
nécessaire pour aller vers la
reconstruction de notre pays et pour y
aller vite c'est de poser la question de
notre indépendance et des conditions
majeures de la dépendance française et
européenne et pour ça il faut dans le
domaine de la production renouveler les
capacités de production dans notre dans
notre ensemble européens français et
européens alors vous dirais que que je
suis un certain parce que on a fait une
et non pas une présidentielle semble
il ya quelques années cette campagne
présidentielle elle était fondée autour
de produire en france produire en europe
et à l'époque y compris beaucoup de nos
amis considéré que c'était réactionnaire
vraiment un cas nul fiable où
l'impensable d'aborder les problèmes
sous septembre
ça c'est la première espérances il ya
une deuxième question qui est la
vitalité de la société française
la vitalité scientifique la vitalité
dans le domaine de la recherche des
inventions la vitalité dans le domaine
de l'entreprise qu'est ce qui peut
qu'est ce qui favoriserait l'esprit
d'entreprise est ce pas il faut avoir en
tête que nous sommes un des pays dans
lesquels la création d'entreprise est la
plus nombreuse
jean noël tu le démentira pas mais après
ce qui manque c'est que se constitue des
entreprises de tailles de suffisante
pour que le réseau d'entreprise et la
dignité nécessaires
ce sont des questions très importantes
et à cette question et naturellement
lier la question de l'investissement à
cette question et naturel naturellement
lier la question de la formation de la
main-d'oeuvre et je vis mal mais comme
tout le monde ça c'est vraiment pas très
original de constater que des métiers
contient ayant un grand besoin de main
d'oeuvre ne trouve pas la manoeuvre pour
un pays où le chômage des jeunes est si
important et donc moi je suis les
heureux que le gouvernement ait réussi à
mettre en place
du point de vue en tissage de la
formation par alternance des mécanismes
qui enfin marche
notre secrétaire département d'autre s
concerne départementale régis laurent
dans les pyrénées atlantiques est à la
tête d'une dune organismes de formation
et il me dit qu'il a 35 % le contrat
d'apprentissage de plus que l'année
précédente qui était lui-même à 15 % de
contrats d'apprentissage de plus que
l'année d'avant et donc le set
c'est un succès mais évidemment ce
succès ne s'arrête pas là parce que il
ya toutes les questions par exemple de
démocratie sociale
je moi je pense que ne peut y avoir de
vitalité du pays que si tous les acteurs
sociaux et démocratiques qui participent
vous voyez que la question de la
démocratie sociale naturelle noël à sa
place évidente au plan c'est tout ça que
je vais présenter le premier plan devant
le conseil économique et social
il ya une troisième question qui est que
le bleu nous ne portons pas seulement
des questions économiques ne portons pas
seulement des questions politiques
d'indépendance mais l'important est
question de modèle de société et notre
modèle de société
il exige que nous abordons ces questions
sous l'angle de la justice alors c'est
par l'angle de la justice par exemple de
jeu reprend l'épisode protection de la
planète et de du client parce que ça
c'est une justice élémentaire que l'on
doit aux générations futures et c'est
par l'angle de la justice que j'ai
l'intention de prendre les questions de
développement je pense à l'afrique et
qui de guillet qui devrait être pour
nous une
dante obligations que le plan c'est fabu
question de justice que je prends les
questions d'égalité de de la situation
de l'as far de des femmes de l'égalité
femmes hommes que je prends la question
de le de de la garantie qu'ils devraient
être apportées à l'ascenseur social
enfin la capacité de progression
d'enfants de jeunes qui sont nés dans
des milieux qui ne sont pas des milieux
de pouvoir d influence et qu'ils
puissent et les gagner et qu'ils sachent
comment pérenne chemin et pour l'instant
personne ne sait quel est le chemin
c'est les familles favorisées initiés
informé qui s'arrange
qu'est ce qu'on fait après le bac
si on va dans une prépare même genre pas
si on qu'est ce que ça veut dire
sciences po tout ça beaucoup de beaucoup
de beaucoup de personnes ne le savent
absolument pas donc vous voyez heures et
là des favelas des questions de alors je
regroupe un peu arbitrairement dans ces
trois objectifs y en aura évidemment
inéluctablement d'autres mais je voulais
vous montrer qu'elle est la manière de
réfléchir
après quelques errements je n'ai pas
l'intention d'établir beaucoup de
marchés entre les questions parce que ce
sont des indices tendent à ceux qui les
vivent et donc est donc bon
mon idée c'est de ces deux villes est la
première j'ai l'intention d'aller très
vite parce que toutes ces questions là
sont des questions qui habituellement
deux nuls à des recherches y très longue
et à des concertations préalables de son
papa
il se trouve que je trouve qu'on a eu
beaucoup de recherches beaucoup de
commissions beaucoup de concertation et
que mon intention est contraire de
mettre tout de suite en exploitation la
mine ils n'ont pas faim la mine
si importante d'études de rapports de
commission fait par les national par le
sénat par france attiches j'ai pu passer
une question souffrent stratégie je
verrai tout de suite quand je retournais
7,7 partie de l'exploser le les think
tanks divers et variés les organismes de
recherche
les universitaires y en a des mètres
cubes d'études le moins qu on puisse
dire est qu'ils sont exploités comme
devrait l'être
et donc je voudrais les mettre tout de
suite en exploitation je vais poser des
questions pour l'instant j'en aperçois
une trentaine regroupés on t'aime je
vais poser des questions mais je ne
prétends pas avoir le monopole des
questions tout neuf a le droit de
demander une question soit traitée dans
le cadre de la réflexion du commissariat
où tout le monde c'est-à-dire les forces
sociales
les organisations professionnelles les
partis politiques nous mêmes les autres
partis politiques français que je vais
recevoir les précédents commissaire au
plan naturellement le mauvais roman ce
disque mais aussi les citoyens les
associations des citoyens
on va on va
ouvrir ce droit et on essaiera
d'intégrer les questions de regrouper
des questions pour que nul n'est le
sentiment qu'on dissimule quelque chose
c'est un exercice où nos pratiques qui
doit être un exercice ouvert
je ne dis pas que sur les propositions
dont je vais dire à mon dans une seconde
tout le monde sera du même avis mais
j'espère que tout le monde reconnaîtra
l'objectivité et de l'impartialité de la
réflexion qui dégagera les questions
stratégiques dont nous savons que notre
avenir dépend france à oui nous avons
des des questions sur l'étape suivante
c'est à dire la manière dont les
recommandations dont les propositions du
frère né à flers seront une prise en
compte dans les décisions et dans la
gestion du pays et delphine par exemple
demande la manière d'autres d'autres ces
recommandations seront pris en compte
comment se fera l'articulation avec le
plan de relance
si tu veux bien jean noël je vous répond
d'abord à la question qui a été posée
par l'un d'entre vous sur comment ça
s'articule avec fran stratégie alors
france cette stratégie vous avez cette
organisation cette institution héritière
de l'ancien commissariat et qui comporte
cent 100 chercheurs 150 collaborateurs
avec un budget important et comment ça
s'articule avec le commissariat
s'articule d'une manière très simple
franc stratégie et on va dire tout
reprendre une formule trempe aussi par
tout le monde est le bras armé du
commissariat au plan ils sont dans le le
oui
[Musique]
le bras la main du commissariat au plan
ils ont fait beaucoup d'ennemis de même
ils ont beaucoup de joueurs de très
haute qualité
ils conserveront évidemment à droite
c'est yves puisque tout le monde et le
décret de création du commissariat et de
ma nomination dit le commissaire au plan
vous voyez que j'utilise à ces deux
adjectifs me semblait souvent appris à
mes élèves que fallait éviter les
adjectifs
ça s'appelle comme ça mais mais oublié
mon altitude ce sera donc le décret nine
commissariat au plan dispose de france à
tj c'est exactement ce que je viens de
l'expliquer c'est à dire francs
stratégie est à la disposition est à la
disposition sans l'ombre iv des travaux
qu'il avait déjà commencé
l'intention du je veux ajouter une autre
chose j'ai vu le journalisme en
interroger 150 collaborateurs budget de
23 millions d'euros
en fait vous êtes riche de ses
privilèges
alors comme vous avez vu je n'aime pas
beaucoup les privilèges et j'ai choisi
d'exercer cette fonction de manière
bénévole et j'ai choisi d'avoir très peu
de collaborateurs
un petit nombre pour reprendre
d'ailleurs c'est pas un hasard c'est pas
de limitation mais c'est le même c'est
le même type 2
c'est le même type de réflexion qui
conduit à la même solution
jean monnet aussi avait choisi d'abord
un petit nom parce que je crois au
commando quand il s'agit de charger le
monde je crois pas au méga
l'organisation je ne crois pas que le
travail soit indexée sur le nombre des
collaborateurs
sans ça il y aurait des réussites
absolument admirable dans les tailles
dans l'administration française et c'est
pas tout à fait le cas donc je crois que
je crois que des hommes peuvent changer
le peuvent changer le monde et je crois
que quinon commando que y arriver
c'était assez dit gardien comme
d'enlever du vénéré fait de retour pour
nous parler donc de la manière dont dans
ses préconisations que vous freine ont
guidé l'action politique peut être pour
leur emploi ont compris les paiements
faits ça peut être notre post et chaque
hiver et je me suis toujours dit que ce
serait sur un plateau j'espère que ça
n'est pas une question
will et les traductions politiques des
recommandations que que vous ferez
comment est-ce que tu le vois comment
est ce que tu vois l'articulation avec
le plan de relance et le rythme de
politique de court terme dans laquelle
on sait dans lequel on la france a fait
enfermer au fil du temps comment est ce
qu'on fait pour articuler une réflexion
de long terme avec une politique qui
s'est habitué à la gestion de l'urgence
c'est pas le même métier jeu alors je le
dis pour les quand vous serez interrogé
par des journalistes qui naturellement
ne rêvent que plaies et bosses et qui
rêve d'un affrontement avec le premier
ministre ils ont compris qu'avec le
président de la république j'avais
insisté pour que ce soit très intimement
liés mais il rêve d'un affrontement avec
bistrot avec tel autre ministre et ils
en seront pour leurs frais il n'y a
aucun risque pour autant que je vienne
bien les rênes il n'y a aucun risque que
nous ayons en affrontement avec le
gouvernement
le métier du gouvernement est de
trancher et de trancher
commandé en attaque pink est donc ici et
maintenant et est le nôtre et de
d'animer les projecteurs sur le long
chemin à parcourir vers l'horizon
atteints de divers horizons et de
dégager les options alors je veux
insister sur ce point
quand tu dit jean-noël les solutions
proposées
je ne peux pas choisir à la place des
décideurs
mais je compte faire quelque chose qui
n'est pas souvent pris en compte en
temps je compte dégager des solutions
cohérentes
je compte mettre en place des stratégies
qui seront des stratégies cohérentes
pour l'avant et y en aura
inéluctablement plusieurs où les
problèmes évidemment se résolvent
difficilement par une seule solution que
des choix à faire nous allons proposer
estoient cohérent ça une vertu c'est que
ça permet
faire échapper le débat aux
affrontements partisans j'appelle mon
partisans au sens large pas seulement
des tic un politique mais passionnel
membres partisans je pourrais en citer
beaucoup imaginent pas le faire parce
que je vais le feu donc mais je ne garde
autant de sujets brûlants
je compte me ses dires nous saisir de
tous les sujets brûlants
mais je ne veux pas trancher dans un
sens ou dans l'autre
je veux dire voilà est devant nous
handala cette voie à cohérente avec les
dangers et les avantages 7 doigts mais
cohérentes avec les dangers des avatars
cette voie c et c est cette décideurs de
choisir à qui sont décideurs ils sont
naturellement et dans l'esprit des
citoyens c'est les gouvernants mais en
vérité les vrais décideurs c'est
l'opinion publique c'est les citoyens
qui commandent par leur influence et
table 20 par les sondages et par qui
commande un action publique et aux choix
qui sont prononcés et ses décideurs là
je pense que la vie démocratique on sera
très améliorée si l'on de vente eu une
analyse d'une situation le l'expression
une question stratégique débuts à
atteindre même si son père à
différencier et autrement
autrement dit alors vous connaissez mais
mes obsessions la démocratie et
l'organisation sociale qui permet de
porter à son plus haut
la conscience et la responsabilité des
citoyens et c'est pour moi conscience et
cette responsabilité
on va largement améliorés et aussi
permettre de se saisir de problèmes
comme la plupart des problèmes dont nous
nous saisirons et traite jamais j'en
prends un exemple très simple le
l'épidémie virale d'une pneumopathie
oui d'une épidémie pulmonaire ce risque
énoncés parfaitement dans le livre blanc
de la défense 2008 casino en ligne
à lire personne n'en a tenu compte
deuxièmement les questions de risque de
danger d'un danger qui se matérialisait
qui arrivent il faut des mois parfois
des années pour qu'on le prenne le monde
je pense que cette question doit être
traitée dans le cadre du commissariat au
plan et vous voyez là le sens de ce que
je porte que que je défends depuis des
années que nous avons défendues depuis
des années et que désormais alors que je
ne le formule est pas pour ça que comme
je dis souvent quand j'écrivais dans mes
livres antérieurs
il faudra un commissaire au plan et
quand une union une capacité politique
importante et reconnu l'opinion et
auprès du président de la république je
ne me projetais pas dans le commissaire
au plan
mais un peu plus tôt dans l'autre
fonction et donc est donc ce n'était pas
vrai j'avais pas pensé ça pour moi que
j'avais pensé par le pays et il me
semble que le le travail de comment je
peux dire de ré enracinement
de la démocratie on a là une possibilité
de le faire vraiment de changer vraiment
la manière dont les décisions politiques
se prennent et se construisent dans le
pont se prennent par les décideurs et se
construit dans l'opinion alors peut-être
vous vous trouverez un peu idéaliste
on va voir si je suivais à liszt ou si
on peut faire vraiment bouger les choses
super soit dès qu'on peut parce que tu
parce que tu es pape est en bonne forme
parce que tu as avant beaucoup dit les
choses
finalement c'est un instinct rééquilibre
un rééquilibrage entre un pouvoir
exécutif clair un pouvoir législatif qui
aujourd'hui est vivant et qui a besoin
aussi de se reconstruire dans notre
bannière de travail à l'assemblée mais
aussi sur la question de la
proportionnelle qui créent qui anime à
nouveau l'actualité de notre pays un
pouvoir judiciaire qui aujourd'hui se
questionne se questionne beaucoup
et finalement ce point d'équilibré en
tout cas je ne sais pas si on peut le
dire comme ça mais d'un d'un pouvoir
prospectifs d'un pouvoir qui projette
l'avenir et qui finalement peut être
sera ce stabilisateur dans une période
où chacun essaye de trouver sa place
chacun est percutée voir bousculer dans
dance est essentiel françois il ya
beaucoup de questions en fait tellement
impressionnant parce que elles sont des
échanges très riches et c'est justement
sur ce que tu viens de lui je me suis en
effet répondre à quelques journalistes
que en fait il y avait le le pouvoir
législatif le pouvoir exécutant qu'il
faut pas voulu les législatifs par son
initiative et au fond il manque un
troisième bol qu'on va essayer de
construire c'est le prospectifs
législatives exécutives prospectifs
alors le prospectifs il a cet avantage
et cette pré couture que le grand de
pouvoir à personne où je ne marche
une et l'intention de marcher sur les
plates-bandes de personnes parce que ça
n'existait pas ça n'existait plus parce
que on avait oublié que ça pouvait
exister et qu'on considérait que tout ça
au fond c'était des vieilles une aide et
qu'on répond sacrifièrent à des études
pour des chercheurs bien sa tactique
mais ça ne changeait pas la grille donc
je ne veux entrer en conflit avec
personne et je ne prends de pouvoir à
personne mais si nous arrivons au but
que donc je rêve nous rêvons
si nous y arrivons on donnera plus de
pouvoir décideurs aient plus de pouvoir
un citoyen on leur prend pas des
pouvoirs
on leur donne une partie du poids parce
qu'ils y verrons mieux et qu'on conduit
mieux la voiture le mot s'il n'y a pas
de brouillard ou le bateau si on a une
bonne météo
voilà voilà pour répondre à ceux
utilisés recommence ça va
sacré de l'espoir parce que qu'ils me
complet de l'actualité
le débat va dire politique ou publics
comme aujourd'hui la place de la
politique familiale delà de la question
démographique de nos pays ou encore
comment réconcilier des choses qui nous
paraissent opposé en tout cas dans la
dans la lecture journalistique
l'industrie et l'environnement
comment redonner foi et cher à une
élimination comment finalement et c'est
les questions qui reviennent ce qu'il a
dit au début
comment permettre à toute une à toute
une génération qui n'a peut-être pas les
codes parce que pas transmis pâtre pape
a reçu à la maison comment leur
permettre cette émancipation je sais que
ce mot est aujourd'hui est dit est
reportée par beaucoup mais dans ta
bouche ça ne sonne pas de la même
manière comment finalement recréer cet
espoir collectif qui fait que l'on
réussira à traverser les prochaines
décennies
mais avec devenir quasiment
chevaleresque j'ai envie de dire avec
panache
c'est ça à l'espoir que en tout cas je
on arrive à lire entre entre les lignes
dans les questions parce que nous ne
l'avons jamais aujourd'hui dans une
période où et des transitions
comment enfin et pourquoi enfin prendre
ce temps et la méthode que ça peut ça
peut avoir
donc si je devais résumer parce que
évidemment je je me suis écouté je me
rends compte que c'est absolument
illisible pour toi en quelques mots tu
crois au commando nous croyons au
commando comment réconcilier comment
créer de l'espoir pour notre société et
un petit su un sujet qui revient quand
même en filigrane et nous avec comment
recréer de la dynamique démographique
dans nos pays parce que c'est le
fondement de notre de notre modèle
social
alors c'est eux disent 'on premières
questions politiques ou plutôt si bill
est ce qu'il y à un moyen d'échapper à
la brutalité des affrontements partisans
et très souvent 1
ma conviction est que oui on peut en
partie échappé à cette brutalité et
fabrique du rassemblement dès l'instant
on se mettra d'accord sur le cadre dans
lequel on doit agir quelles sont les
contraintes
est-ce qu'on accepte de les nommer
quelles sont les évolutions en cours
dans le monde qu'on peut formuler à
notre propre usage est en effet proposé
des chemins les voir à des stratégies
pour en sortir
je suis persuadé moi je pense que que
que le le court terme et fait ni
l'affrontement et violent le moyen et
long terme permettent des rassemblements
permettent de se mettre d'accord au fond
madame l irish vous n'êtes pas d'accord
à des noirs résidant dans un autre camp
mais si nous devions définir ensemble la
france 2 dans dix ans printemps 30 ans
nous produisons que je retiens 10 ans 20
ans 30 ans au fond un couple se mettre
d'accord
est-ce qu'on le plat comme dire que le
pouvoir citoyen ne peut s'exercer que
dans un pays indépendant
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec moi mais
est ce que cela est d'accord pour dire
que le la société française sera plus
forte
si on a une réalité de justice sociale
et comment y arriver
voyez
dit comme ça dix questions que la france
ne compte pas ignorer les réalités
changement qui m on peut ne pas être
d'accord sur ghost d'imaginer qu'il ya
des débats importante que ne pas être
d'accord et en tout cas à la question de
savoir appareils changements climatiques
la réponse est oui mais c'est par
exemple nos émissions de gaz à effet de
serre que cette médaille et vous voyez
toutes mes questions damas sont des
questions qui prennent un tour
stratégique rassembleur parce qu'on peut
se retrouver sur l'horizon ce qui divise
c'est ce qu'on va faire a fait comme il
ya des enjeux électoraux mais pas tant
les enjeux à proprement parler
électoraux on est devant des enjeux
démocratiques
jean noël oui on a une question qui
rejoint les propos que tu que tu viens
de tenir et notamment celles qui
concernent la vitalité démocratique
c'est thomas qui demandent quel est ton
avis sur la montée des populismes un peu
partout dans le monde sur je dirais le
discrédit qu'on peut détecter dans les
enquêtes d'opinion réalisées auprès des
jeunes où on voit que la confiance dans
la démocratie décline
nous sommes le mouvement démocrate
quel est ton avis là tu es comment est
ce que nous on peut participer à cette
défense de la démocratie qui est fille
qui a l'air d'avoir perdu une partie de
son lustre
alors je vais m'exprimer là non pas
comme commissaire au plan
mais comme citoyen avec sa propre grille
2010 pourquoi populisme moi je viens de
ce que les citoyens ignorent absolument
la réalité les contraintes et qu'on ne
leur a versé de partager les objectifs
je pense que c'est une question de
développement culturel du niveau je
pense que comme toujours la violence et
de guillaume dès l'instant que la vision
assuré du réel alors je veux bien et le
sait les intégrismes c'est la passion
qui prennent la main c'est les
superstitions qui prennent la main et
donc il y a un gros travail se
reconnaîtra dans ce que je vais dire
d'éducation populaire d'éducation
civique populaire au plumeau sens du
terme faire vous êtes citoyen j'ai
encore un certain nombre de questions
sur lesquelles on donnera des faits
c'est fait pour être discutées mais on
veut aller vite pour en sortir pour en
sortir des orientations
moi je
ouah ça je crois beaucoup que ce que on
peut choisir ce chemin encore une fois
on pourra me dire que c'est un peu
optimiste et un peu idéaliste mais si je
n'avais pas choisi une fois pour toutes
l'optimisme réalisme sans doute je
serais pas en train de répondre à vos
questions
c'est ça va être là c'est une question
de vie ou de mort alors on a envie de
l'inviter
j'ai envie d'en garder une une qui qui
marque peut-être toute l'intensité de
nos échanges
comment permettre à chacun finalement
dans sabri d'appuyer sur pause pour se
projeter aussi à 10 20 ou 30 ans en
gardant de l'espoir puisqu'aujourd'hui
on a on va avoir l'occasion de le faire
collectivement à 10 20 et 30 ans et
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui revient c'est
le mels et malvina clients qui le pose
entre l'instantané et la projection sur
ces trois temps comment les faire vivre
et quel est pour toi peut-être le mot
que chacun doit peut-être mourir pour
être acteur de cette de ceux de notre
pays de cette société qui se transforme
mais qui a des sybelles qui a tellement
de choses en un mot d'énergie un mot un
mot d'espoir finalement alors un moment
pour le l'efficacité de l'action qu'on
va entreprendre ce mot c'est crédibilité
et authenticité
j'espère que vous aurez senti que en me
lançant dans cette aventure
je ne fais pas oeuvre partisane même pas
pour un parti que j'aime que l'on sent
que nous avons su faire lettre est
préservé
je n'exprime pas de préférence je veux
que ce soit crédible et authentique
auprès de nos concitoyens si tel est le
cas ne souffre d ivoire va pas
et deuxièmement qu'est ce que le quel
est le nom dont je crois et c'est pas
pour te faire plaisir
sarah quel est le nom dont il pourrait
être le le maître mot de cette période
ses engagements
on se heurte à son meurtre deux ennemis
depuis très très longtemps depuis depuis
le début de ma vie politique
l'autre nuit c'est le à quoi bon les
gens qui croient des gens là l'immense
majorité des gens y compris des acteurs
politiques c'est ça qui va super fête et
au long de ma vie publique
les acteurs politiques ne crois pas
qu'il puisse changer le monde
ils croient pas ils y pensent que l'on
ne peut rien faire et si vous y
réfléchissez l'abandon d'un plan
s'arrête pas autre chose que la
traduction de ceux de sète
fondremand debra baisse les bras mais il
ya un deuxième était encore vous avez
accord qui est que la plupart des gens
non seulement il ne croit pas qu'il
puisse changer le monde mais c'est pire
il ne croit pas que le monde puisse
changer parce qu'ils vivent comme s'il y
avait une fatalité que c'était voilà que
les cartes étaient distribués comme
peut-être les jouer un peu mieux mais et
moi je ne vois pas ça je pense qu'il ya
des lois alors je pense que en économie
jean-noël la noire du profit maximum est
une loi pour la plupart des entreprises
pour la poule des genres vaut mieux
gagner dix de gagner un
et quand on prête on attend d'être enfin
s'attend à être remboursés c'est des
noirs et doit être que demain mais les
lois disent croire les lois condition
humaine
les noirs en profondeur commandes des
bleus
toutes ces voix là elles peuvent changer
et on sait bien qu'il arrive assez
souvent qu'elle change pour le pire
mais il arrive aussi quelquefois que de
grands mouvements de l'histoire les
charges pour peut-être pas le meilleur
mais un peu meilleur et ça c'est bon
c'est mon guide c'est ce que je pense
d'eux que doit être l'action responsable
démocratique
et puis tout simplement d'un citoyen et
puis tout simplement d'un homme ou d'un
père de famille ça pour sa propre vignes
pour celle de ses enfants si hollande a
cessé c'est tout ça que je considère moi
comme
comme au fond le le grand moment qu'il
faudrait obtenir dans les consciences et
si je peux et si je peux avec vous parce
que naturellement quand je dis tout ça
est ouvert à tout le monde c'est ouvert
à tout le monde
avec un ticket de priorité pour vous
dire est que que vous avez un ticket des
priorités de profits voilà merci en tout
cas de ceux de ce face à face je
regrette de pas avoir attendu en direct
est question je les avais même pas sur
l'écran sans ça j'aurais essayé de
distinguer les uns et les autres mais
merci de cet exercice qui correspond aux
faux à ce qu'on faisait avec une belle
de samedi soir à l'invitation lancée aux
adhérents militants simples
sympathisants du modem a participé aux
travaux du plan et bien rencontrera des
dés de l'engagement puisque c'est
quelque chose qu'ils ont exprimée sur
les dents les remarques dans les
questions que nous avons reçues que nous
n'avons pas eu le temps de tout adressé
mais en tout cas merci beaucoup d'avoir
pris le temps de cet échange
cher françois merci beaucoup à toi sarah
d'avoir pris le temps d'être avec nous
pour ces questions et puis on vous donne
rendez-vous dans dans un quart d'heure
pour le forum des députés et des
sénateurs la soirée se poursuivra et
vous aurez à nouveau rendez vous demain
avec françois bayrou pour le discours de
clôture
bones farage sorbonne systémique parce
que je peux dire à mon de remerciement à
la can et technique si j'ose dire c'est
à dire à tous le giga vincent delphine
qui ont fait en sorte que ça marche et
le multi guaynabo et donc vous avez été
tous formidables parce que si les gens
tiraient avec quels moyens nous faisons
ça il y aurait jamais avec du coeur
en commando bravo